pete alonso out uh before the game today
playing catch with some fans you know
he's been working on his defense so hard
he yeah he's even doing it in his off
time he's trying to help others i made
some nice plays last night he did oh
that's got it that is great fans
i mean how much do fans love that right
there phillies attempt to win the series
and finish this six game home stand with
a five and one record and they think
they've got the right guy on the mound
to do just that aaron nola who started
on opening day
and was a pitch away from getting
through seven scored his innings he's
looking for win number one on the season
nimmo getting ready on the left side
against the right-hander aaron nola
bouncing ball past the map tough play
for sakura not in time and nemo beats it
out for an infield hit so a demo is
aboard to start the first inning
so francisco lindor will step in with a
runner aboard check swing another slow
roll should be able to give cover
second base is nimo and one out for
conforto he has three doubles in a home
run lifetime against nola
rolls over on the right side noah's
there to cover good feed from reese
hoskins 3-1 on the put out over to third
is nemo two outs and a runner at third
base for pete alonso
over to short stop charging gregorius
he'll take the big hop and throw on the
run in time
so they didn't get the ball out of the
infield they did leave one over third
now david peterson off of an impressive
albeit truncated rookie season will go
to the mound wearing a real pitcher's
big league number now 23 having chucked
77. that's more like that's exactly
right goes to the high fastball and
mccutcheon pops it up into shallow
center
nemo looking through the sunglasses and
that's the first down and that'll bring
reese hoskins up last year against
left-handers 3 41 with four home runs 12
runs batted in out toward right field
going back on it is conforto back to the
scoreboard it is gone
just over the small fence a solo shot to
straight away right and the phillies
take the one-nothing lead peterson's
difficult first inning continues home
run to hoskins double the harper and now
a walk and alec ball will come up with
two men on last year as rookie hit 452
with runners in scoring position
onward left center field that's well hit
nemo's going back it is gone
off the back row of the last row
a three run home run broward balm it's
four nothing philly's on top boy nothing
like jumping out to a big lead right out
of the chute so the mets have two men on
now peterson first major league at bat
curveball he tried to check doesn't
matter called strike three second
strikeout for nola so two up two down as
peterson looks to bounce back after that
rough first it's four-nothing phillies
and it'll bring up reese hoskins
and he lights it to left field that'll
be in for a base hit and rolling all the
way to the wall hoskins on his way to
second base he's gonna have his fifth
double of the season it's his sixth
extra base hit
and harper goes down swinging
to retire the side so one out still
first and third and now alonso who mets
with an opportunity to climb right back
in this game
line toward the middle of the diamond it
goes into center field on base heads
nemo comes in with the mets first run
the mets are on the board it's now a
four to one philly league now dominic
smith will represent the tying run swing
and a miss curve ball
third strikeout for nola that's a big
one still one more man to get in this
inning it's jonathan vr swag and a miss
he got him with a four seen fastball at
94. back-to-back strikeouts for aaron
nola to put out the fire aaron nola
normally is good for
six or seven innings he's having a hard
time getting through the fourth and
still has a three run lead it is four to
one phillies so the bases are going to
be loaded here with two outs in the
fourth inning and it's going to bring
michael conforto to the plate mets are
just one for nine with runners in
scoring position that's a lot of
opportunities early in this game
strike three right on the outside part
of the plate
he has dashed in and out of traffic all
day long he dashes in and out once again
he leaves them loaded the mets have left
eight through the first four reece
hoskins is three for three a homer and
two doubles he's got a lead off two base
hit here in the fifth inning bryce
harper will come to the plate he bunts
up the first base line alonso has it no
play and harper a bunch single over to
third is hoskins first and third with
nobody out now barnes inherits the first
and third no out jam
as he makes his mets debut now he'll be
thrown right into the fire to face jt
rail muto when a new pitcher comes in
rio muto loves to jump on the first
pitch the first pitch to him
fly ball right field it's fairly deep
conforto's going back to the wall it is
gone
three-run offensive field home run for
jt
it's the second three-run home run of
the day for the phillies and they're on
top 7-1
even the bench was pointing first pitch
first pitch here's bradley
the mets having runners at first and
second two out here on the top of the
sixth inning philly's leading seven to
one michael conforto is oh for three
swing and a miss this time and conforto
is out
a lot of runners left on base 11 through
six innings stolen base for quinn of
third a stolen base of mccutcheon the
second and now the mets will move the
infield up with a count oh and one to
harper ground ball
diving stop alonso it'll get a run home
as alonzo takes it to the bag eight to
one so now to add mccutcheon at third
with a run in and here's rail muto
grounded toward the middle and lenovo
with a good grab the spinorama and he
got him oh wow what a play
that is the golden glove of francisco
lindori takes a basement away from ray
mutto and then going up against ray
mutto's speed
one hop throw to get him and vr winds up
with a well-struck triple well the mets
have had hits in every inning bounces
away and vr will come in to score
so on the wild pitch vr scoots home
to make it eight to two joey lucasi will
make his mets debut
strike three called as lucasy
gets his second strike out both on call
third strikes inside basketball in there
strike three called on the inside corner
three strikeouts for lacazee who's
retired all five that he's faced three
outs away from winning the series over
the matson going to 5-1 to open the
season
throws it again on one hop to segura
he's got it and the ball game is over
the phillies have won back-to-back
series
they swept out the braves they take two
of three for the mets they win it eight
to two this afternoon the long ball
helped the fills to the victory and
that's a heck of a way to start a home
stand